nato is not a threat to russia and we
remained ready to engage in dialogue and
find the diplomatic way forward it
remains to be seen whether there is a
russian withdrawal we are of course
monitoring very closely
what russia does in and around ukraine
what we see is that
they have increased the number of troops
and more troops are on their way
so
so far
no de-escalation
but of course uh uh we
we we hear also the messages about about
diplomacy and and we are ready to engage
in diplomatic efforts with russia
um
[Music]
we haven't yet seen that it may happen
in the next 24 hours or 12 hours what we
had seen was as of yesterday the
opposite we saw
large field hospitals being built in a
number of districts around ukraine
and indeed we saw continued deployment
from holding areas into more forward
areas that may all change i mean
we'll see as i've said when i visited
moscow last week we shall judge them
not on their rhetoric but on their
actions
on the ground the physical observations
that we see
show the opposite of some of the recent
rhetoric coming out the kremlin and i
think it would be absolutely the right
thing to say is that you know that is
not normal military exercising you don't
surround a country with a hundred plus
you know 60 percent of the whole of
russians land forces on its borders if
you're just going for an exercise
is
in the last two days
russia has signaled that it may be open
to diplomacy
and we urge russia
to take concrete and tangible steps
towards the escalation because this is
the condition for sincere political
dialogue we cannot eternally attempt
diplomacy on one side while the other
side is amazing troops